x-men apocalypse is directed by Bryan
Singer and stars the x-men of the Year
1983 Michael Fassbender as magneto and
yes Deadpool McAvoy not Stewart in this
film the ancient being known as the
first mutant apocalypse played by Oscar
Isaac is set to wreak havoc on the earth
as he tries to ensnare various mutants
including magneto to join him in his
destruction of the entire planet as he
feels that mankind has lost its way and
that they follow blind leaders I found
this to be an ambitious movie and in
some ways a very risky movie there are
strange head trippy sequences in which
McAvoy takes on someone inside his brain
and you get to see the metaphorical
battle take place in a physical way
unexpected comedy at unexpected moments
involving Quicksilver all kinds of
things that make this film in my opinion
pretty damn great I saw this film
earlier today it was very excited I saw
with a friend of mine it was cool to see
it so early
I knew the embargo lifted today at 5
p.m. Eastern but I had some stuff to do
I had some work to do at home and I
didn't get a chance to really get my
review up until now but I decided you
know what I'm just gonna look at the
reviews and see what people are saying I
am blown away by how mixed negative some
of the reviews are it's definitely not a
perfect movie it has its flaws don't get
me wrong I'm just going to sit here and
talk about how much I love the x-men
there are issues with this movie and
it's storytelling and for me the biggest
was the first 20 to 30 minutes I found
that it was a little bit slow in regards
to slow I don't just mean slow paced it
took me a while for me to care the
opening sequence is in Egypt you learn a
little bit more about Apocalypse and his
backstory and I just had a hard time
getting invested in it it felt a little
scatterbrained for the first few minutes
and I was like huh I really hope this
film picks up and I think some critics
actually check out sometimes when a
movie just doesn't grab you from the
first scenes and I honestly think that
happens but in the case of Bryan
Singer's x-men films he's made three
really good x-men movies already and so
I'm willing to give him the benefit of
the doubt and what I found with
Apocalypse is that after one very very
amazing scene involving magneto in a
forest I was hooked and for me
personally this was that rare film that
got better with each scene got more
investing I got more involved with it as
the film played on and that's hard to do
usually films are a little more rocky or
they're pretty much just good or
terrible all the way through
I found this film was actually sort of
like each scene was a stepping stone for
the very next one to get even better
this film balances a lot of different
characters you have introductions to
characters like Cyclops or Scott Summers
and they did a great job with him ty
Sheridan was very good as that character
there's more drama between the professor
and Magneto again and those two roles
and the way they clash for me are some
of the most fascinating elements of the
entire x-men saga and once again McAvoy
and vos bender play wonderfully off of
each other and there's some really for
me personally some heart-wrenching stuff
towards the last act which let's talk
about no spoilers of course it's very
action heavy there's tons of CGI
green-screen lots of fights and actually
it might be the most action heavy finale
of any x-men film that I can really
think of in regards to just ship flying
everywhere and sometimes that can really
not work because the film can lose focus
of the story when you have all this
stuff happening but I found that the
very personal human elements of this
story involving characters like Jean
Grey who really gets a chance to shine
in this movie and McAvoy and the inner
demons of his brain it really provided
some depth for me and I liked the way
this film tied in to the future x-men
films that we know already let's talk
about something I was a little off and
on with and that is apocalypse Oscar
Isaac is a fantastic actor I love this
guy way before I ever saw him in force
awakens I thought he was a terrific
terrific actor and virtually every part
he took inside Llewyn Davis Drive he's a
very talented actor in this movie I
think he's very menacing he is a
presence to be reckoned with the way he
speaks the voice effects they added to
his audio was very dark very scary very
ominous but those first twenty to thirty
minutes I had a tough time really
getting involved with apocalypse at
first I was like oh man this might be
really corny because I couldn't really
get what his character was going for
what his goal was but it eventually
becomes more clear and I think it's the
type of movie that as you go back and
re-watch you'll start to understand why
certain things are set up because as I
said those first 30 minutes they do drag
a little
because they are trying to set up so
many different characters and so many
little nooks and crannies of things that
you don't really feel the full arc of
until maybe even the last ten minutes
and that's a long time to wonder why
certain plots and story elements were
set up in the beginning and during that
time of watching it I kept thinking to
myself are they really needing to
explore all this oh nice I feel it now
right there and I can honestly say as
someone who watches films from a
critical standpoint and who really likes
to examine film that is a problem that I
personally have as a film critic
sometimes you don't always get the
answers immediately and you wait until
the end and then you're like oh I just
spent the entire film annoyed with
little hints of things that I shouldn't
have been and when I go back and watch
it a second time certain things are
going to feel more rich now that I know
why they're there and I think Bryan
Singer and the writer Simon Kinberg did
a pretty ballsy thing with this movie
it's weird sometimes it gets a little
trippy there are strange head trippy
sequences and it paid off in the end for
me also I got to say Quicksilver Wow so
great I did not think they were going to
be able to top his awesome sequence and
Days of Future past but they did and
enjoy it because it's awesome also no
spoilers don't worry there is a sequence
in this movie I was extremely excited to
see people said there was a very spoiler
heavy trailer that was recently released
so I didn't watch it so going into this
film I didn't know of this amazing
sequence that I got and man was it good
man it was good I was very happy to see
that so is Apocalypse as good as Days of
Future past for me it might just be a
little bit below it there are some
narrative issues with the first 20 to 30
minutes where it took me a while to get
into the story after an amazing sequence
in the forest with magneto the movie was
great from then on but those first 20
minutes were a little bit rocky
narrative Lee there are times where
Apocalypse and his performance goes off
and on sometimes his motivations aren't
very clear but again as I said the film
builds and gets steadily better and it
kind of trusts you to wait and be
patient
and that's something that you don't see
too often in comic book movies nowadays
and I have to give them credit for being
ambitious I'm gonna give x-men
apocalypse and a - I don't agree with
the critics on this one I mean maybe
after a few weeks there'll be some more
positive reviews but right now and I'm
posting this I think it was like a 40
percent or something I'm Ron Tomatoes
when I looked and I was just like I'm
not feeling it this time guys I'm not
feeling it I think this movie is better
than you're saying and that's just me so
guys I have heard your request I didn't
forget about it I am absolutely going to
review Captain America the 1990 version
in a Larry ASSA tea form I have the
freaking blu-ray and I watched it and
don't worry I'm going to review it but
when I got this kind of last-minute
x-men apocalypse press invite that kind
of took precedence and I hope you
understand that review still coming you
guys are the best thank you so much as
always for watching I greatly appreciate
it and if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes